[Music]
eddie
is with us eddie's in san antonio hi
eddie what's your question
mr ramsey dr dolomi thank you very much
for taking my
phone call um got a 22
18 and the 16s they're
22's in college right now she's got a
pretty good head on her shoulder i'd let
her walk out the door
with a 10 000 in her pocket and great va
and
texas veterans benefits that she really
doesn't have to worry about much
i hate to say i think i fell
short teaching my sons
financial planning and budgeting i
thought i'm everything else
but i didn't get to i don't think i did
any better
than with my daughter he's the 18 year
old
in his senior year high school 16 year
old was a junior
they're going to walk out of the house
with about 10 000 themselves too and
also the same va benefits and
the hazelwood act over here in texas i'm
just
what else do i need
to teach them or to show them what they
need to do
so they don't have this phone call with
you
yeah 10 20 years in life i'll jump in
and then john
john spent a bunch of years in higher ed
i want him to chime in on this
but i'll jump in they're not leaving the
house with ten thousand dollars to start
with
they're gonna leave the house with a
budget monthly that they're to live on
and that they have helped develop so
they believe it
and then i'm going to fund that budget
out of that 10 000.
you don't hit the lottery because you
graduate from high school and get a 10
000
check and pray god you know you don't
have a kid a car car keys and didn't
know how to drive
you show them how to drive yeah i i
even even with my daughter it's
monitored
i get to see what you spend yeah but
that's too late it's too late
you don't give her the ten thousand
dollars you give her money out of the
ten thousand dollars monthly
to fund the budget that the two of you
together worked up and you're doing it
together
this is what happened with the ramsey
kids all right so what should he do john
i hey eddie i want to challenge a
language okay
you just say you failed them with a
period at the end of that sentence and
i'm going to disagree with you
there is no greater gift there's other
gifts
a great gift that dad can give his sons
is to take him out to breakfast and say
i left out a critical thing
a critical piece of information and i'm
gonna look you 18 year old son you're a
man now i'm looking in the eyes and tell
you i'm sorry
i'm going to put us through financial
peace university we're going to go
through it together we're going to do
this playing together
i'm not too much of a macho texan to
say i wish i'd done this differently
when you were younger i didn't so here
we go
and so failed has appeared at the end of
it i don't like that man
you're going to show your kids some
vulnerability then you can tell them you
love them and then like dave said
you're going to not just hand him the
keys to the car and say man you're 18
now i hope you make good decisions
because we got enough brain science and
we have enough um
newspaper headlines to show us that 18
year olds don't make great decisions
because they're 18
and 16 year olds are 16 year olds man so
the greatest gift you can give your kids
is this continual i'm learning i'm a dad
i'm still on a journey i'm still
figuring it out and i'm going to stop
you every time i see you and i'm going
to let you know what i'm learning
i'm going to be vulnerable with you and
i'm going to make you do it the bad news
is i'm going to teach you the good news
is we're
we're on it now the other bad news is
we're about to learn it together
and we're going to do it that's right
the bad news is you got to do it anyway
and the kids are going to learn by
watching you yeah they're going to grow
from watching you
exactly so good for you eddie yeah hold
on i'm going to have
kelly send you a copy of the book smart
money smart kids that rachel and i did
together there's some good instruction
in that
along these same exact lines but um yeah
well just put them through financial
peace university put them in ramsey plus
too
that way they can do what john suggested
he and the son can go through it
together that's a good idea